- All right before we say goodbye,
I have one more story of
positivity, I wanna share.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
All right, y'all,
it's almost the official start of summer
and that means laying by the
pool or heading to the beach.
I know a lot of people
dread this time of year
because, well, it means
putting on a swimsuit
or even worse, a wet suit.
Which is the worst thing
in the world to put on,
if you've ever done it.
It's SPANX from hell.
(crowd chuckle)
Well, now there's an organization
that's helping encourage
wetsuits for all body types,
I welcome this, but even more than that,
they're promoting body
positivity among female surfers
and we can all use that message.
And on the line right
now to talk about it,
is the founder of Curvy
Surfer Girl, Elizabeth.
She watches on Hawaii News
Now, what's up, Elizabeth?
(crowd applauding)
(crowd cheering)
- Aloha y'all, Aloha Kelly (chuckles).
- Oh my gosh.
- Thank you so much
for having me.
- Absolutely.
But does everybody look just fabulous
and beautiful and glowy in Hawaii?
'Cause I need to move there.
(both laughing)
Elizabeth, what inspired
you to start this movement?
- Well, I really wanted
to show that every woman
of any size, age, background is capable
of surfing and being an athlete.
And so we started the
Curvy Surfer Girl movement
about two years ago to do that.
You know, when I first started surfing,
I really felt excluded from surf culture
because I am a plus size, curvy woman.
And unfortunately at that
time, there were no swimsuits
or wetsuits that were
being designed in my size
and it just made me feel left out.
And so I said, "You know what?
Rather than waiting for
the surf industry to change
let's get a community together
and make that change happen ourselves."
- I love that initiative.
So, this is really working.
What's happened since
starting Curvy Surfer Girl?
- So, since starting Curvy
Surfer Girl, I partnered up
with one of the largest surf
brands in the world, Rip Curl
and I got eight curvy and
diverse women together
and we did a massive surfing campaign.
It was heard around the world
and since then it's
just continued to evolve
and include more and more women.
I've actually partnered
up with small businesses
and we've been working
to expand swimsuit sizing
for performance wear,
whether you're free-diving,
you're surfing, you're jet skiing,
you're inner tubing, it
doesn't really matter,
we all need performance
swim to do the things
that we love in the
water and in the ocean.
So, that's what we're here doing
and it's just continuing to grow.
Recently, I started working with JOLYN
and we're gonna be coming out with our own
extensive plus size swimsuit
collection for surfing
and it's going to include
wetsuits next spring.
- All right, make those
easier to put on ma'am.
Thank you so much, Elizabeth.
(crowd applauding)
This is such a cool thing
that you're doing, not only
for yourself, but so many.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(heart dinging)
- Thank you.
(Elizabeth laughing)
- All right,
and that's not all, our
season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show want
to celebrate those creating
fearlessly, just like you ma'am,
so they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars, how's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my god.
(Kelly chuckles)
(Elizabeth laughs)
That's amazing.
- Oh my gosh, well have a great day.
Thank you so much, Elizabeth.